[Music]
my name is Michael Kyogoku I'm Emily
Ewan and we are owner and chef of beso
restaurant chicken karaage is Japanese
style fried chicken every country has
some type of fried chicken
simple love dish and Japan is no
exception in Japanese cuisine chicken
thigh is used for Corrigan's oftentimes
marinated in soy sauce and it's you know
form of fried chicken but it tastes a
little bit different from Southern Fried
Chicken where you know shake and bake
fried chicken it's made with potato
starch so it makes it extra crispy on
the outside it's double fried so in that
process of double frying it's somehow
taste slight even though it's fried food
and I think that's what people are most
interested about so when we make chicken
first we marinate the chicken overnight
with sake mirin and soy sauce marinating
the chicken overnight in the soy sauce
and the mirin which is a sweet socket
brings out some of those kind of sweet
savory notes of a traditional karaage
and then we make a story using eggs and
flour and then we dip it in potato
search and shake it off after we put
potato starch on it we fry le lower
temperature for about 10 minutes and
then we'll take it out let it rest for a
half an hour and then we'll fry at a
higher temperature for about two minutes
it just becomes a little bit more crispy
when you fry at the second stage that's
always what we're looking for a mu
crunch
carga is usually flavored by the
marinade
but then our twist to it is putting this
almost kind of shwarma mix spice dusting
on top to give it a little different
this the spices consists of like paprika
some salt cumin coriander cinnamon
cayenne garlic butcha baru dry parsley
at the restaurant we serve larger pieces
of chicken thigh to mimic traditional
American fried chicken but normally in
eASIC ayahs or at palm karaage is a lot
smaller they're like almost like chicken
nuggets
that's another nod to New York as
opposed to you know sticking with
tradition in Japan Christmas time is
synonymous with fried chicken a lot of
people go to KFC and get a bucket of
fried chicken and it's like a real party
who doesn't love fried chicken
everything that we have on the menu we
always try to bring like a memory from
our home whether it be her home or like
my home beso means home away from home
and we want people to enjoy and just
kind of share and not have too many
formalities and kind of past the dishes
around like you would at home
you